um tell me kind of like uh for people
who don't know you have GT digital which
is your distribution Distribution
Company yep and these days there's so
many distribution companies popping up
right everybody's trying to do it a lot
of people try to do it they just can't
get clients well that's what I was going
to say for you like uh cuz I'm really
you know obviously I'm real tight with
gazi and Ne and those guys and as you
are you do a lot of business with Empire
as well there's companies like um Dro
kid toor and one RPM there so many
independent Distributors these days uh
what is the what do you bring to the
table that is unique I think that being
my my years of being in the record
business you know black and brown
entertainment there's Latin records
knowing how to be a record label and the
the the necessity of communication
dealing with the artist people do want
to give you their life of their heart
and then all of a sudden you got to talk
to a email and you can't speak to nobody
you know with us I have a staff we're
going to talk to you I talk to you I
listen to the music I'm I'm in tune with
everybody and there's a lot of artists
out there you know what I'm saying but I
I'm able to uh decipher who really wants
it and who is necessary of that time to
talk to them of course everybody is and
we do I believe there's enough time in
our day to talk to everybody that's the
whole thing I don't you know we want to
talk to you I give you 5 minutes to chop
it up with you see what's going on how
are you doing with your marketing what
do you need help in let me listen to
your best song first thing I do what's
your best song right what's your best be
let me see it you know what I mean that
ain't nothing this is what I'm doing I'm
in the music business I want to listen
to the music you know there's some
people that there's other companies that
don't do none of that you that is true
you got to send an email you got to yeah
that's it this your kid ain't listening
to your [__] to you think them
[__] they is not listening to
your [__] they don't give you you just
loading it up putting it in you going to
get they goingon to get their money they
going to pay you that is it hard though
like uh trying to be accessible to
everybody
you know what actually it ain't n yeah
it ain't because most people most I'm
going say most artists are only doing an
album or
two so they they're putting they some
some [__] they forget about
they even put something up right you
know what I'm saying then you got some
that are seriously into it and then you
you could talk to them they're going to
put something out I mean it's it's you
know like I said 10-minute conversation
is going to go a long way yeah I think
that's what he does different you know
because like he was talking about the
communication I think when there's
communication with comprehension it
changes the dynamic of just
communicating when you communicate with
comprehension you understand what you're
talking about and I think he's really
good at that he's really good at letting
them know like look this is a b and c
this is the way it's supposed to happen
you do your part I do my part everybody
wins instead of like oh my shit's out
all over the you know in every platform
right so what yeah the drro game is
interesting because I just see I feel
like every major label has their own
version of I guess what Empire I feel
like kind of revolutionized in terms of
like you know they kind of kicked the
door down and now everybody everybody's
got their own empire under their
umbrella you know like 300 has Sparta
and you know go on and on and on so I
just always am wondering like you know I
just I'm intrigued by the business and
gazi both started off with ingrooves
Ines is I was I started I started I
started ing Groves as rap division that
was their first rap I was their first
rap label Maxi hooked up guysi with them
for the job for him to get in there
that's crazy you know what I'm saying
gazi was you know my engineer for black
and brown entertainment at that time you
know what I'm saying so I mean we go
he's still engineering too he just
engineered the whole album you know it's
the true cuz like there's there's a uh
YouTube video of gazi saying I want to
be like Julio when I grow up I'm like
now gazi blew up that mean all this to
say is at any point you could get you
can blow it could take one day any point
man in this game it can happen you know
dreams can happen overnight over with
the you know stuff goes viral all of a
sudden boom you're on I was going to ask
both of you guys cuz you guys each have
had so much independent success in the
rap game I feel like I always correlate
the Bay Area with like just the the real
roots of this independent rap [__] like
getting it out the trunk you know what
I'm saying yeah how do you guys like
being on both sides of the game right
like in 2023 the music game so different
there's got to be like other ways to
monetize your music besides the
streaming CU streaming is you know it is
what it is I mean cross marketing of
course with other artists you know what
I'm saying paying for you know getting
ads YouTube ads Tik Tok ads doing
marketing you spend money gotta spend
money man you know and it may not come
back you know at least you gave your at
least you gave it a shot to shine though
and you got to be okay with that yeah
you got to be okay with you got to be
that's acceptance of that is a huge part
of being an artist you know what I'm
saying I i' I've always been a firm
believer of that like sometime deac choa
says expectancy determines outcomes when
you're not attached to the outcome the
outcome is guaranteed
sometimes that desire and that want
creates an actual barrier between you
and your success I think you know of
course doing your visuals
too it's the truth I think your visuals
too you got to get in you you got to get
creative with your videos and your
visuals you know what I'm saying yeah
sometimes the song you think is the one
may not be and you got to be okay with
that and you got to be okay gamble bro
everything this is all the gamble that's
why I say like I have fun with this [__]
man like when he wrote the song having
fun with I'm going to go do a video both
we having fun that's what I do with my
music that's how I enjoy it if I spend I
go spend 10 20,000 [__] if I don't make
it back at least I have fun doing doing
it ask when he told me about the music I
was like ah bro that's like fifth on the
list for me you know what I'm saying cuz
it is you know I'm the bringing the
culture together doing these festivals
all over the country you know closing
that paradoxic divided SL divided Gap
yeah I mean you've been doing your thing
as a promoter for a long time a long
time yeah which is an whole other side
of the game is yeah you know but again
resource and strategy you know there
have been some shows that didn't go so
well so what there's been some shows
that were phenomenal yeah there's some
records that didn't do so well so what
some records that did phenomenal yeah
I've been on Power 106 I've been in
Boise like you know it doesn't matter
yeah you know every single aspect of
what you do to contribute to what you're
doing matters you know what I'm saying
so I think a lot of artists have this
idea this fallacy of what they're
they're dreaming and there ain't nothing
wrong with that but ultimately you can't
let money consume you it's got you got
to have passion for what you do you got
to have passion for your art you still
got one of the things that people say
about Floyd Mayweather is that he was
still train like he was broke for sure
you know what I'm saying like the
passion has to be your purpose your art
I always look at music like art that's
why it comes so naturally I've been
doing it for a long time but I was never
like a ABC person just to do songs to do
songs especially as I got older and
especially as life itself became more
meaningful to me relationships become
more meaningful you magnetize and Ally
with other people that are living a
meaningful life and then whatever you do
becomes meaningful so therefore it
happens organically